the rel do you know
what the realm is it's the thousand
blades of Aegon's enemies a story we
agreed to tell each other over and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of therns update
video well it finally looks like there
are some new developments surrounding
one of the many Game of Thrones
successor shows as you all know HBO
already filmed one episode for a new
show titled Blood Moon this one will be
set thousands of years before the events
of Game of Thrones right around the time
of the Age of Heroes so far this is the
only successor show that has been given
the green light to this extent however
it looks like a second show might be
getting the same thing some recent
developments have been released which I
want to go ahead and take a look at now
deadline says exclusive hold your
dragons Game of Thrones fans another
prequel of the hugely popular fantasy
series is eyeing a green light I've
learned that HBO is close to giving a
pilot order to a game of Thrones prequel
from another author in Game of Thrones
co-executive producer george RR martin
and colony co-creator executive producer
Ryan Condal
which is said 300 years before the
events in Game of Thrones and tracks the
beginning of the end for House Targaryen
the network declined to comment
created by Martin and Kondo and written
by Kondo I hear the project is based on
the fire and blood book by Martin and
has been in the works at HBO since last
fall according to sources the condo
Martin project is not a 6-game of
Thorne's prequel I hear it represents a
brand new take on a world originally
tackled by Bryan cogman in one of the
five Game of Thrones prequel scripts
commissioned by HBO in 2017 former Game
of Thrones co-executive producer cogman
confirmed in April that his prequel idea
was not going forward in typical martin
fashion the author has been dropping
clues about the House Targaryen prequel
project all alone we have had five
different Game of Thrones successor
shows in development at HBO and three of
them are still moving forward nicely he
wrote on his blog in May one of the
three is the unentitled prequel written
by Jane Goldman and starring Naomi Watts
which shot a pilot this summer the
project now in post-production in a
waiting word whether it will get a
pick up Chronicles the world's descent
from the Golden Age of Heroes into its
darkest hour to other shows remain in
the script phase but are edging closer
Martin wrote in May what are they about
I cannot say but maybe some of you
should pick up a copy of fire and blood
and come up with your own theories
coincidentally are not a large image of
the fire and blood cover was featured
just above this section in the same blog
post with a note about the book success
having just re-entered the New York
Times top 10 best seller lists where it
had previously spent more than three
months you can't keep a good dragon down
Martin wrote about the feet named after
House Targaryen z' words fire and bloods
first volume was published last November
with the tagline 300 years before a game
of Thrones dragons ruled Westeros the
Targaryen history book a companion to
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire saga
goes back to a time when House Targaryen
the only family of Dragonlords to
survive the doom of Valyria took up
residence on Dragonstone fire and blood
starts off with Aegon the conquerer
creator of the iron throne and goes on
to recount the generations of Targaryen
who fought to hold the throne all the
way up to the Civil War known as the
dance of the Dragons the war will be a
significant part of the TV adaption I
hear Game of Thrones which is based on
the acai sand fire featured a couple
surviving Targaryen including Daenerys
Targaryen
Viserys Targaryen and Jon Snow at TCA in
July HBO programming president Casey
boys would not comment on the status of
the other Game of Thrones prequels
besides the watts pilot but did not roll
out the possibility for another game of
Thrones offshoot to get a green light by
the end of the year it's something I
would not comment on he said all right
now deadlines already sort of mentioned
this but it doesn't make sense for them
to take a show in this direction when
you consider Georgia or Martin did just
release a book about the history of
House Targaryen
not to mention House Targaryen was one
of the four major houses from Game of
Thrones so most of the built-in audience
should have some interest and learning
more about the family I know I do now
that this information is on the internet
hopefully HBO will release their own
statement confirming it along with
giving us some more details so it does
look like Blood Moon will mainly focus
on the Starks and the White Walkers
whereas this new show will focus on the
Targaryen 's and their dragons let me
know down below which show would you be
more excited to see
I've always been interested in things in
the north especially when it comes to
the Starks and their early connection to
the White Walkers but I will happily
watch any show based in the isang of Ice
and Fire universe now before I get too
excited I want to wait and see if HBO
releases a statement about this other
show in the meantime maybe I will
finally make a video about House
Targaryen and some of their history
similar to some of the videos I have
made about House Stark let me know if
you would be interested in seeing
something like that anyways I just
wanted to give you an update because it
has been a while since some exciting
news has broke if any other information
is released I will be sure to make
another video as soon as I can I want to
thank everyone for watching the video
and supporting the channel I really
appreciate that and I hope you all have
a great day I will see you again soon
bye
[Music]
you